not only were they voting for the new
house leadership yesterday but then
Trump makes the announcement and just
everybody and their brother is here
right now so why don't we just uh start
with that so yesterday uh well first
we'll show you the Tweet so yesterday uh
Kevin McCarthy this is from the daily
wire breaking Kevin McCarthy has been
elected the Republican nominee for
speaker of the house so the Republicans
it sounds like they officially have the
house so that is good although it wasn't
as big of a landslide as some people
wanted if you want to break up a little
bit of the power right the Democrats
Stranglehold on what's going on here in
America and on all the policies you at
least want a broken government so that
the Republicans have at least some
degree to stop some stuff so Kevin
McCarthy who has been the House minority
leader will be the House Majority Leader
there's some tension whether he's Maga
enough or America First enough or
whether he's establishment okay fine
everyone's gonna have their little
political fights but anyway yesterday I
we were at the Capitol and we were at
the Senate building and I met with
Senator Marcia Blackburn over at her
office's really lovely lady we're going
to have her on in the new year and then
we took the trolley there is an
underground trolley that goes from the
Senate building to the Capitol and we
were going to meet with Kevin McCarthy
just a few minutes before they announced
that he was going to be speaker we had
to jump on the trolley and try to get
there here's a quick 30 seconds of what
the trolley was like as you'll see it's
very Willy wonka-esque
all right guys so I am on the trolley
right now from the Senate building to
the U.S Capitol of KissAnime Senator
Marsha Blackburn uh I think Ted Cruz is
right there
Ted Cruz right over here did you turn
the camera we got it okay uh what I mean
there's a crate
and that was Elizabeth art
[Music]
I also walked by Michelle wilinski from
the CDC in the uh in the building over
there did not say hi anyway I guess
we're here that was like a Willy Wonka
ride okay
anyway I thought that would just be a
fun little Insider thing to show you
it's just sort of like the on the
Underground the underbelly of the
capital you know where AOC was hiding on
that fateful day uh but it's funny when
you see these people like obviously I
know some of these senators and Congress
people at this point but to see Ted Cruz
just walking there's Elizabeth Warren
right behind him it's like that they're
doing business together and Elizabeth
Warren with her like three thousand
dollar fancy purple uh pantsuit or
whatever she's wearing whatever that
dress was and it's like she's a
socialist worth 50 million bucks okay
fine anywho the theme of the show today
obviously is that Donald Trump has
thrown his hat in the ring he has
announced he is running president for
2024. it's kind of nutty because it's
super super early I think basically what
happened was he thought the Red Wave was
a coming he wanted to announce right
after so that he could connect himself
to the Red Wave Red Wave didn't happen
but the plans were already in motion so
he announced his speech was was
excellent last night like I think it was
objectively if any of us are objective
these days it was objectively an
extremely good uh clear and cogent
speech with a with a good argument
around it so we're going to play some
clips of that and then we'll talk about
what the fallout's going to be and how
the media is going to react and uh you
know does America have a future I think
we're going to be okay let me talk to
you guys about uh Patriot Supply real
quick friends are you prepared for empty
grocery stores if the diesel fuel
shortage gets worse Joe Biden is in
charge apparently listen if trucks can't
get the fuel they need you won't be able
to buy all the food you need that's why
there are so many people stocking up on
emergency food right now it's easy fast
and affordable go to prepare with
reuben.com and you'll save 250 on a
three-month emergency food kit from my
Patriot Supply my Patriot Supply is the
nation's largest preparedness company
and they're charging less so they can
help families more go to prepare with
reuben.com and get your three-month
emergency food kit that's packed with a
wide variety of delicious meals
breakfast lunch dinner drinks snacks you
won't go hungry when you have this kit
be sure to get enough to feed your whole
family through the winter these three
month kits are in stock and ship fast
with free delivery but don't wait and
sell in soon go to prepare with
reuben.com right now that's prepare with
reuben.com right now oh I should mention
guys
before we get into some of the Trump
stuff that we are live streaming right
now at our normal time 11 A.M Eastern at
noon Eastern today so when we wrap this
show up at about 11 45 about 15 minutes
later we are doing another live stream
Ted Cruz is going to be joining us
Senator Ted Cruz and we're going to go
for about a half hour then I got to jump
on a plane I'm going over I'm going back
to the free state of Florida to the fox
Patriot awards for a couple days but yes
so we have two live streams today there
will be another one at noon Eastern with
Senator Ted Cruz and we'll obviously
talk about Trump and much more so let's
get right into it so Donald Trump
announced he is running for president
once again last night he did it from uh
his home at Mar-A-Lago and here's a bit
of the announcement in order to make
America great and glorious again I am
tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
people say how do you speak before so
many people all the time if when there's
love in the room it's really easy if you
want to know
you
ought to try it sometime
together we will be taking on the most
corrupt forces and entrenched interests
imaginable our country is in a
horrible State we're in grave trouble
this is not a task for a politician or a
conventional candidate this is a task
for a great movement that embodies the
courage confidence and the spirit of the
American people this is a movement this
is not for
any one individual there's a job for
tens of millions of proud people working
together from all across the land and
from all walks of life young and old
black and white Hispanic and Asian many
of whom we have brought together for the
very very first time
all right so it was a solid speech
obviously the energy in the room was was
amazing and uh you know he he's back
right he's back whether whether you like
it or not he's back I suppose you
watching this right now obviously have a
huge amount of trump supporters that are
in this audience I think I have some
people that have kind of moved on and
would like to figure out something else
maybe I have people that never support
him in the first place like it's all
over the place my general feeling is you
can like a whole bunch of people you
know you want a robust primary to me
that is the best possible thing as long
as you're all not demolishing each other
as long as it's not scorched Earth and
we are wrecking human beings it's like
you actually do want a battle right you
remember the video that I played of
Jordan Peterson talking about this a
couple days ago it might be best to have
a battle a hardcore Republican battle
about what is the future of the party it
might be best to have that battle
publicly and if you can do it and and as
much to the degree that you can keep it
about policy and about why your vision
is the best vision and not just make it
about personal attacks and everything
else and this is where Trump I think is
going to have to perhaps be a little bit
more disciplined it's like then that
will be good but the the general tenor
of the speech I thought was excellent
because basically he was saying hey look
when I was doing it it was pretty good
we're going to show you a clip on that
in just a second but he was saying it's
just not right right now and and only
the movement that I started is the thing
that can stop it now you may you may not
agree with that or you may uh be
completely in line with that but it is a
sound argument for someone to run for
president like I did it for four years
things were good look at it now I'm the
guy that can come in and fix it it's
clean and clear and it makes sense
here's Trump reflecting on his
presidency in contrast to Joe Biden
the world was at peace
America was prospering and our country
was on track for an amazing future
because I made big Promises to the
American people and unlike other
presidents I kept my promises I kept
all right look at the end of the day
Trump did keep an awful out of his
promises look we had a more peaceful
world than we have right now there is
simply no doubt about it right we did
not have this crazy war in Ukraine the
Abraham Abraham award uh the Abraham
Accords were signed Middle East peace
was a thing that we were all into right
that was something that we all used to
want suddenly Trump did it and it became
a Bad Thing uh the economy was chugging
along you guys all know it about black
unemployed black unemployment being the
lowest It Ever Was Latino unemployment
being the lowest It Ever Was give me
just one second here
I've been interviewing people all
morning there's a lot of talk in my
mouth's a little dry
um his argument is is sound when you
compare it to the Biden Administration
but there's something else that really
is driving Trump to run it's not just
like I can tweak this policy or I have
better economic policy on this or or the
wall or that sort of thing there's
something else that drives the America
first movement and that drives Trump and
it is that Swamp Thing I happen to be in
that swamp right now but he referenced
it last night we must
conduct a top to bottom overhaul to
clean out the festering rod and
Corruption of Washington D.C
man I mean that really gets to the heart
of it right like what did Trump run for
in the first place you know when we
played you that clip uh of uh oh no we
didn't play that was on the Tim pool
show that I was on the other day uh when
Trump was talking about uh sorry when
Dave Chappelle was talking about Trump
and he was watching that first debate
and you know Trump is basically saying
hey you guys are all the liars I'm not
paying taxes because that's the rules
that you guys set up that means I'm
smart it's like Trump is going after the
Swamp Thing I can tell you look I'm here
in DC right now there there is a big
superstructure I don't think it's all
inherently evil it certainly wasn't set
up to be evil but it's calcified here
you know people come from their states
they come here to try to make things
better you know nationally and they
usually make things worse that's just
how it is so Trump's main argument is
that hey it was pretty decent under me
it's been pretty bad under Biden and I
did not get to finish what I started I
did not get to drain that swamp and
everything else let me just say
something else about what what the Trump
struggles are going to be first off the
question is can he bring in any new
voters who are the new people that are
going to suddenly vote for Trump I mean
if you didn't vote for Trump last time
are you going to suddenly vote from I
suppose there could be some disaffected
Biden people that might say okay I'm
going to go for Trump this time but in
many ways a lot of them voted for Biden
the first time because they hated Trump
so it doesn't seem like that's a ton of
people now if Trump announces we know
that a whole bunch of people who
wouldn't vote otherwise will vote purely
because they hate him so he may have
seen his max already right if he got 75
000 75 million votes last time
he may have seen what the ceiling looks
like and the question is if a whole
bunch of people come vote against him
well Biden did beat him last time you
can talk about fraud you can talk about
anything else but that's also what Trump
has to address if he believes that he
has said it many times he believes that
they stole the election from him last
time what have you done to secure the
election this time why would they not do
it again by your own argument right I'm
not saying it's true or not true right I
don't have any more insight into into
that than any of you do
um but we were all around on Election
night when he was leading in eight
states in a pipe burst in Philly and
then a week later we don't know what the
hell is going on so it's like if he
earnestly believes that and again I
think that he does well he has to
explain well here are the ways that
we've secured elections so that they're
not just going to do it to me again so I
think those are the two I think those
are the two main problems he has right
the the ceiling we sort of know it and
the floor uh could be a problem and then
this issuer around fraud and then the
other part is you know if and I don't
want to make everything about DeSantis
but if DeSantis gets in who has been the
standard Bearer for all of the ideas
Trump has been fighting for and has done
everything that a right-leaning
conservative ex-lib Freedom loving
person could do if you're if your goal
is to just wreck him in the name of
becoming president again I think a lot
of people are not going to be into that
I I did sense last night and we were at
a restaurant in DC watching so there's a
whole restaurant of people watching
um you know my sense is people are going
to be a bit over the attacks I know that
the the trolling works and the joking
works and the name calling works and all
that but I I don't know that that's
going to work with DeSantis if he does
get in because people really really
appreciate his competency and and the
other thing is as I tweeted it's like
you know if they want to frame him as
establishment I can see a lot of the the
major Trump people trying to frame
DeSantis as establishment right now and
it's like well if the established guy is
the guy doing literally everything you
want keeping the state open fighting the
the mandates you know securing elections
all of those things well then isn't that
a pro-establishment argument but anyway
we're gonna have plenty of time to talk
about all that let me tell you guys
about story worth and then we'll move on
you know this holiday season I want to
give a gift to my loved ones that makes
them feel special and unique just like
the relationship we share that's why I'm
giving everyone I care about story worth
story worth is an online service that
helps you and your loved ones preserve
precious memories and stories for years
to come it's a thoughtful and meaningful
gift that connects you to those who
matter most each week's story worth
emails your relative or friend a
thought-provoking question of your
choice from their vast pool of possible
options each unique prompt asks
questions you've never thought to ask
like what's the bravest thing you've
ever done in your life or if you could
see into the future what would you want
to find out with story worth I'm giving
those I love most a thoughtful personal
gift from the heart and preserving their
memories and stories for years to come
go to storyworth.com Reuben and save ten
dollars on your first purchase that's
storyworth.com Reuben to save ten
dollars on your first purchase
so because the lead-in to this Trump
announcement uh we knew about it right
like everyone kept saying that and there
were a few people and I was hearing it a
lot yesterday people were like oh maybe
Trump isn't going to announce tonight
maybe he's going to announce he's
running as a third party candidate or
he's announcing that he has dirt on
Biden or Hunter Biden laptop or whatever
but the basic consensus was the guy was
going to announce last night so team
Biden clearly Was preparing for this and
they released an ad against Trump just
minutes after he announced nobody has
ever done what we've done in the last
four years their entire economic plan
tax cuts for the rich and corporations
and record-breaking unemployment the
worst jobs report on record Trump is the
only modern president to leave office
with fewer jobs than when he took office
it's bizarre how they didn't mention
covid in that and how the entire machine
was forcing the economy to shut down and
yes Trump does have something to answer
on that right he absolutely does and
Trump was for a certain degree of
lockdowns he was pushing a lot of it
back to the States Trump also did
Operation warp speed and he was you know
he's been very positive on vaccines and
then they kind of turned out not to work
this is a place where DeSantis I think
has a uh a little bit of a uh event
where he can blow up the Death Star
because he's been so anti-v vaccine
mandate and everything else Trump trump
I don't think was for the mandates per
se when the mandates came around that
was from the Biden Administration but
Trump really was pushing and pro-vaccine
anyway they'll they'll have to work that
out again if if it happens or not but
the fact that the Biden administration
had a commercial ready to go
anti-trump tells you that they really
are worried about Trump even though this
thing is two freaking years away it's
two years away we got a lot of this
stuff that we're gonna have to do uh
here's a funny you know those meme
makers of the internet uh a funny little
video of trump pushing back on bud if
you're a middle class family you're
getting hurt badly right now you're
sitting at the kitchen table this
morning deciding well we can't get new
tires with their ball because we have to
wait another month or so talk about
North Korea
10 seconds Mr President 10 seconds go
political statement let's get off this
China thing and then he looks the family
around the table everything just the
typical politician when I see that let's
talk about a typical politician okay
that's why I got elected come on Joe you
can do better
I grew up in a family
where in the price of gasoline went up
at the pump it was a conversation at the
kitchen table with my dad where prices
went up for things were daily
requirements like the gallon of gasoline
it became a discussion of the kitchen
table it mattered felt it was a
discussion of the kitchen table you felt
it was a discussion at the kitchen table
around your kitchen table on our kitchen
table felt at the kitchen table on the
kitchen table and around our kitchen
tables around the kitchen table in the
morning feeling your own lives around
the kitchen table talk about around your
kitchen table and I learned that at the
kitchen table in Scranton my dad used to
say the end of the day it says when you
sit at that table come on Joe you could
do better we're going to talk about
North Korea now
foreign
they're all going to come back all of
the videos with Trump's face on movie
characters and all of the stuff it's
It's All Coming Back people all right so
what is the media going to do about this
right there's a really interesting setup
and I've been warning about this for
weeks before this there's going to be a
super interesting setup with the media
because on one hand the media hates
Trump they think Trump is evil and he's
racist and a Nazi and all that stuff on
the other hand the more that they talk
about Trump the more people watch right
so people tune out of CNN when they're
not talking about Trump they tune out of
MSNBC so they have a vested interest in
propping up the guy that they think is
evil and or at least that they say is
evil so that they can get people to
watch then there's another weird dynamic
developing here which is I think that
the
the machine itself is more fearful of
Ron DeSantis than it is of trump because
DeSantis obviously can bring in a whole
bunch of new voters DeSantis doesn't
have some of the negatives that Trump
has he his track record has been nearly
Flawless he's fighting the media the
same way all of that stuff he's younger
he's a family man okay fine so because I
think they're going to view that as more
of a threat MSNBC and CNN and Washington
Post the places that tell you Trump is
Hitler and everything the more that he
goes after say a DeSantis if it happens
the more that they're gonna have to be
kind of like oh Trump is the good guy in
this situation so it's going to create a
really weird system of selective
pressures where on one hand they're
going to be telling you he's the evil
most evil thing ever and on the other
hand but you know he really hates the
other evil guy and you know we kind of
like that Evil's a little lesser than
the other evil or something like that
here is a televised mental institution
MSNBC Nicole Wallace uh on how the GOP
is gonna Burn It Down
Alexi they're so far away from this I
mean they are they are running they ran
as arsonists trying to burn down our
democracy and now they want to put on a
firefighter hat and help put out the
fires I mean it is so it's not like oh
we had different opinions and and maybe
we can come around to seeing the wisdom
of yours they were working to damage our
democracy and now they want to I mean I
just I just think it is it's too far to
travel
as my friend Viva fry who's a frequent
guest on the show says that's confession
through projection uh Yes actually I
think Republicans have been making
arguments now maybe those arguments
didn't translate down to the average
voter uh because you guys control the
media and big Tech and everything else
but she's saying it's not like we have
different opinions and maybe we could
come around to seeing the wisdom of
yours well but we do and there are
obvious differences between being a
Republican and a Democrat and again I
don't want to make everything about the
polarization of two political parties
um but there are fundamental differences
uh things like individual rights and
states rights and lower taxes and no
mandates these are all things that I
think are winning things we have to
convince more people that they are
winning things
um but it was the Democrats who were
using the power of the state to silence
people via big Tech right it was the
Democrats who were using the power of
the state to force companies to inject
their employees with things when the
government and giant corporations work
together against you the individual
that's known as fascism the same thing
they're always calling us you see how
they do this and then of course there's
all these non-profits that are are just
grifting extraordinaries I would say the
premier one is probably the Lincoln
project now you may remember the Lincoln
project this was a bunch of sort of
ex-republicans these were these were
McCain and Romney Republicans who were
so disgusted by Donald Trump they became
this group of never Trump people and
they got millions and hundreds of
millions of dollars to be principled
conservatives who never accomplished
anything but they were better than that
Donald J Trump guy who was doing all of
the stuff that they purported to want to
accomplish but never actually could well
the Lincoln project which is super well
funded which said that it was a
republican you know the whole idea of it
was we're here for conservative values
we want to save the Republican party but
we just don't like Trump well now the
mask is off with these guys here is
Lincoln project senior advisor Stuart
Stevens on what the Lincoln project
really actually does want to do just to
be clear I mean it's a LinkedIn project
we're not trying to save the Republican
Party we're trying to burn the
Republican party to the ground
that's an incredible admission
like I don't know if that was planned or
not planned or what but the whole idea
of it Lincoln project right Republican
project we are just going to remove
Trump from this equation and we're going
to keep fighting for Republican
principles limited government okay you
guys got it for him to admit no we
actually want to destroy the entire
Republican party and they get tons and
tons of money obviously from Democrat
donors it's like grift alert if you see
anything from the Lincoln project you
gotta know that it is BS and nonsense
and a whole bunch more speaking of BS
and nonsense how about the view uh
here's Joy Behar and she really doesn't
want this Trump guy to run and she wants
the government to stop him okay
Trump is a wounded animal this is the
exact time when Merrick Garland should
swoop in and indict it this is why
because bouncing well that's exactly why
he's announcing it already Merrick
Garland is a day late Nadal short he
should have done that this morning
before this guy announced yes but he
didn't do it yet which makes it now it
looks as though it's political which is
what Marigold was trying to avoid
once again confession through projection
right they admit what they are while
sort of claiming it's what we are right
they we're the fascists she's literally
saying that the Attorney General should
have arrested this guy in essence so
that he couldn't announce he's running
for president that's not really how it
works in a free Society with due process
Joy also for the last six years we've
been dealing with this whether it was
Russia collusion an impeachment one and
he drank water with two hands arrest the
guy and 25th amendment him and he fed
some football players hamburgers and he
eats his steak with ketchup these are
all horrible things he used he has two
scoops of ice cream and he must be
stopped even though Joe Biden's always
eating ice cream and it's fun when Joe
Biden does it anyway the idea that
Merrick Garland should be looking at
whatever whatever evidence or
non-evidence he has from the Mar-A-Lago
raid right you know
again it's just so obvious nothing's
going to come of that it really is
obvious I was off the grid in August
when it happened when I came back in
September I was just like well oh it
just sounds like another one of the
things like it's another one of the
scandals that's a non-scandal oh my God
Donald Trump Jr had lunch with a Russian
for 15 minutes in 2015 on the Upper East
Side my God we must impeach his dad they
want to keep this endless hysteria but
it's it's not just about the endless
this area they want to use the levers of
the state to in essence jail and stop
their political opponents I don't think
Republicans are doing that are they I
don't think so but we got more from uh
from The View here's some excellent
political analysis by noted racist Sonny
Austin gotcha moments like haha that's
jiren Martha's Vineyard now look how
clever I am I thought he looked like the
devil in doing that it did yes Rhonda
santis looks like the devil because he
sent a couple people up to Liberal Haven
Martha's Vineyard you know you didn't
care sunny when these people overrun all
the Border towns in Texas you just don't
care about those people because you
think those people they live in Texas
and they're backwards and stupid so they
should just have it but if they freaking
send 20 migrants or 20-year legals to
Martha's Vineyard it was nuts you guys
all know the story within 24 hours the
National Guard the entire media
establishment everything turned so that
they could boot these people roughly 20
people they could boot them off Martha's
Vineyard Barack Obama has a 30-acre
waterfront mansion He could have put up
a tent
we would have sent it to him I would
have sent him a few tents to put up in
his backyard actually it's his front
yard because they got a great view of
the ocean over there but they did not do
that uh anyway what of course is coming
with all of this Trump stuff is what is
the Republican party going to do are
they going to go this route are they
going to go a more DeSantis route or
another route altogether and of course
Trump was kind of going after DeSantis
this week he had this Ron de
sanctimonious line which kind of fell
flat people weren't into it he sent out
a couple messages on Truth social sort
of going after DeSantis and the question
was is DeSantis ever going to respond in
any way and actually yesterday we got
the first sort of uh toss-in on that
so we'd like to know what you think
about trucks big announcement and some
of the less than flattering comments he
has made about you
well you know one of the things I've
learned like learned in this job is um
uh when you're do when you're leading
when you're getting getting things done
yeah you take incoming fire that's just
the nature of it I roll out of bed in
the morning I've got corporate media
Outlets that have a spasm just the fact
that I'm getting up in the morning and
it's constantly attacking and this is
just what's happened I don't think any
Governor got attacked more particularly
by corporate media than me over my
four-year term and yet I think what you
what you learn is all that's just noise
and really what matters is are you
leading are you getting in front of
issues Are you delivering results for
people and are you standing up for folks
and if you do that then none of that
stuff matters and and that's what we've
done we focused on results and
Leadership and uh you know at the end of
the day I would just tell people to go
check out the scoreboard from last
Tuesday night the fact of the matter is
I mean that's right that's the right
answer right you just keep leading you
know that if you do the right thing
you're going to take fire whether it's
from the media or your political
opponents but then if you do the right
thing you look at that scoreboard and
you go holy cow I just crushed it with a
20-point win and have super majorities
uh in the house here in Florida where
I'm in DC at the moment but back home in
Florida and we helped a guy like Marco
Rubio with a landslide win and the state
is strong so this again
I like both of these guys I do I very
proudly voted for Donald Trump last time
and it cost me a lot it cost me friends
uh it cost me career opportunities a
whole bunch of stuff there is a
situation in which I would vote for him
again I obviously like DeSantis a lot
there is absolutely a situation that I
would vote for him for president
etc etc
the question is what Will trump do if
DeSantis just keeps his eye on the ball
right keeps running Florida keeps doing
all the things that the people want to
do and makes his
his case for his future if he makes it
airtight I am competent and decent I
pick my fights accordingly I secured
elections I don't force people to inject
themselves with things and you know the
machine is going to just keep coming on
him but if he stays disciplined and on a
message I don't know that the attacks by
Trump are going to work
and again maybe there's a way that of
ultimately there's a tag team operation
here I don't know about President and VP
but there might be some way to put these
pieces together but I can tell you I I
definitely sense people if if all Trump
is going to do is throw the kitchen sink
at DeSantis the personal attacks and
whatever else that might be and I heard
a rumor that you blah blah
I don't think that's going to work I
think people are over that and I think
going after people for the personal
stuff you know if if going after people
for the personal stuff destroyed people
anymore then Trump would be long gone
right grabbing by the [ __ ] etc etc so
that that's where they'll have to figure
it out I think the other interesting
thing with this is that as I said before
what new voters can Trump bring in that
is it's a really hard question right
that's a hard argument that he's gonna
have to make oh I can bring in all these
people but when you take all the
disaffected Liberals when you take the
ex-democrats when you take the
independence that's a huge group of
people right one of the reasons we
didn't get the Red Wave is because the
independence and the disaffected
Liberals they either stayed home or they
they stayed primarily with the Democrat
Party Ron DeSantis clearly can bring
those people in how do I know that well
I even got a guy like Bill Maher to
admit that he could vote for DeSantis
and there's no way in high hell he could
vote for Trump if California yeah says I
have to take shots
and DeSantis says I don't
hello Florida
that's what I'll say about DeSantis
he's a good dude he's a good dude
he really is and he doesn't care either
you smoke weed and he doesn't care who
you marry just he doesn't but to sound
like the uh
voiceover and a movie that's coming out
soon
[ __ ] just got real
but like for me personally really [ __ ]
just got real with that yeah and that's
that's in my mood I left this place
because of it and I don't want to leave
the leave this place that it would be
very hard
so that is the standard bearer of
liberalism arguing that there is a
situation where the Biden Administration
or the Democrat States the blue States
got so out of whack that he could vote
for DeSantis I don't mean to make this
all about Bill Maher okay and I get it
this election time like he was on TV on
MSNBC and a bunch of other things
telling people to vote for Democrats to
save democracy so my my work will still
continue I think I'm doing the show in
January and I'll I'll push him once
again uh but the idea that okay he he
does represent an important sliver of
American society of the people that can
move one way or another and he's saying
hey he could do the DeSantis thing
that's interesting but let's talk about
the broader picture here it's not about
Trump or DeSantis or even the left it
really isn't all of these leaders good
bad ugly they're the consequence of us
the American voter that is just the
truth it's what we put out there is what
they reflect back to us and regardless
of political party Americans are
obviously fed up everyone in this town
in D.C there are all walking around
today going what in the high hell is
going on here so whether they know it or
not they're yearning to return to a time
of normalcy and comfortability I really
think that's it people want competency
they want something decent they want
something that we once had Senator Josh
Hawley who we thought we were going to
get in studio today it doesn't look like
it's going to happen because it's so
crazy he was out in the Capitol here's
something he had to say about this past
election and what has to happen with the
Republicans now I think that this
election was the funeral for the
Republican party as we know it the
Republican party is as we have known it
is dead and voters have made that clear
and in particular the folks who did not
vote for republicans in this last
election were independent voters working
class independent voters folks who voted
for President Obama Once Upon a Time
folks who then voted for President Trump
but stayed home this time
we are not a majority party unless we
can appeal to those voters
yeah I mean he's not sugarcoating it
he's saying the Republican party is dead
now I I don't think it's dead to such a
degree that he's saying mayor but we're
gonna have to split hairs on the on the
verbiage exactly the point is the
Republican party has a huge opportunity
right now
huge opportunities right now if it did
not go the way you wanted it to go
roughly a week ago
uh even though okay you got the house so
there are some good moments here right
but if it didn't work out and you got to
look at those Independents and those
working-class people it's like you got
an argument if you're Donald Trump you
absolutely have an argument hey it was
better when I was when I was doing it if
you're around DeSantis you got an
argument look at everything I've done in
Florida and I won by 20 points so there
is a rich opportunity now for
republicans and I think the more that
they grab the mantle of hey we are not
here to solve all of your problems I
know an awful lot of people a huge
amount of people way too many people
they just want more stuff from the
government right that is the that is the
Democrat promise and there's a whole
bunch of people who don't understand why
that's not really the American way so if
40 of the electorate just wants more
stuff they want higher taxes so that we
can take from some and give to others we
have to accept that that is reality and
we can wake those people up when we can
but it is not in the American ethos we
have to return to something like Ronald
Reagan was talking about in the 80s
which is that government is the problem
not the solution in this present crisis
government is not the solution to our
problem
government is the problem
from time to time we've been tempted to
believe that Society has become too
complex to be managed by self-rule
that government by an elite group is
superior to government four by
and of the people
well if no one Among Us is capable of
governing himself
then who Among Us has the capacity to
govern someone else
ain't it the truth that's just what we
have to get back to and Ronald Reagan
was a two-term president who won his
second term in an absolute Landslide
absolute Landslide and it wasn't because
he came in saying I'm going to give you
all of this stuff he actually did the
reverse now did he keep all of his
promises did he did government grow
under him all of those things okay fine
none of these people are perfect right
Jesus ain't showing up to run for
politics uh run for president or
anything else but it's a mindset that I
think we have to shift to it's a mindset
that's aspirational and maybe that's
what the opportunity is right now maybe
that's what the battle that we're about
to be confronted with within the
Republican party is going to be all
about that's a that's a good battle to
have which way are we going with all
this but it's not all political right I
always say the answers are not all
political they're sort of spiritual
they're sort of within your own mind how
do you want to live because then you
reflect that in the type of people that
you vote I found this clip a couple
weeks ago of iron Rand author iron Rand
Fountainhead
who I love throwing to some clips of her
we've done over the years because she
often talked about this because she was
not into government she did not like
centralized systems she thought that you
and your value and your capacity to own
your mind and use logic and reason was
the most important thing I absolutely
believed that and here she is talking
about how we shouldn't be criticizing
virtue because that will lead us to Envy
it's a little yoda-like I think you're
going to dig it the worst thing today is
the attacks on ability the uh I call
this today's atmosphere the age of Envy
actually
and I asked you whether you would be
attacked by people for your success and
I don't know whether you want to give
the answer to the audience that you gave
me yes yes I am well that's what I
regardless the most Immortal thing on
earth to attack a man not for his flaws
but for his virtues because to make a
success of yourself in any line of
rational activity is a great virtue and
they people will attack you for
exercising your ability for hard work
for consistency for ambition and they
will want to make you feel guilty of it
that is the greatest evil according to
marvelous
man doesn't that feel like something
that that's Iran probably 30 40 years
ago right ability is virtue working hard
is virtue competency is virtue we do
fake virtue we do virtue signaling we do
I scream about something thus I am good
I take from someone else to give to that
guy thus I am good but if we could get
back to genuine virtue and this is a
great argument now for Trump and
DeSantis that they both can have this
argument which is hey we're competent we
did stuff we set out things Trump can
absolutely say hey I set out these
things to do and in four years I did a
whole bunch of them right way more than
most presidents do Ron DeSantis can sit
there and go look at everything that I
have done in Florida this is the
blueprint and I have been competent and
decent and all along but all of the
ideas of success and virtue these are
the things that have been under attack
and when those things are constantly
under attack then you could be in a
place like C where they look at the
people that they are governing over and
they think boy if we can just give them
more stuff whatever that means that'll
keep them docile and that'll keep us in
power so that is the paradigm shift that
I think we all got to work through which
is that it's a it's a mindset shift it's
a spiritual shift and then then
regardless of whether it's Trump or
DeSantis or somebody else or both of
them or who knows what we won't feel
that all of our value is derived from
the political machine and I say that
from Washington DC stick around for a
cold close got a couple comments from
the locals Community Margot says does
anyone else get the feeling Biden never
leaves the kitchen I mean man you know
he's been bouncing around all over the
world right now because of some climate
stuff and these conferences and it's
just like he almost tripped yesterday of
the fumbling and the bumbling but
because the the Red Wave didn't happen
you know he's saying that basically he's
going to run again and uh it's just what
are they doing uh California Runway says
I'm curious who will be Trump's vice
presidential pick I say Carrie Lake well
it's interesting let's just say Trump
gets through regardless of DeSantis
getting in or not whatever it is if
Trump gets through to me it's probably
not carry Lake although I think she has
an extremely bright future especially at
the national level it's too much to the
same thing right if you all of the Trump
people love Carrie Lake you're not
bringing in any new people you would
have to find somebody that gives you a
little bit of an ability to bring in new
people so for example last time Trump
wanted to do he chose Mike Pence it was
like the evangelicals which obviously
are a huge voting block they were a
little nervous about Trump a New York
real estate developer like what can we
make of this guy oh but he's got Mike
Pence with them that'll kind of bring in
some of the evangelicals so usually the
VP VP pick is not about skill per se
it's about uh sort of figuring out some
sort of demographic thing that you need
to accomplish Kamala Harris right I mean
Equity man with her so that's what
they'll have to figure out so I think
that if it is Trump as president he most
likely is not going with a pure pure
Maga guy you're going to try to figure
out somebody that maybe is either a
little bit out of politics maybe in the
business World maybe a little bit going
to that well he's already sold on the
Evangelical base so it's like something
else somebody to make some of the new
conservatives or whatever them more
comfortable at least something like that
Tony says I'm selfish I just got to
Florida I want to keep my Governor I get
it and that's why purse personally look
to me if DeSantis doesn't run it's okay
I'm just talking about for me and my
life and for the for my family and
whatever like that's just reality right
like I want the guy being here for for
more years to 2028 is all good
um if he ran and Trump beat him and he
just comes home and he licks his wounds
and keeps Florida going that's all good
if he runs and he beats Trump and he
becomes president that's all good so
again this is why if you live in a if
you live in a good State and you have
good people around you there there are
good options and people can lose
elections and it still could work out
for you uh so a little something to
think about uh guys if you have not
subscribed join us at rumble.com Reuben
report if you want to play along live
chat during the show and for all sorts
of pictures of all the things that I'm
eating and doing with the kids and a
bunch more join us at
reubenaport.locals.com part one of my
interview with former Wisconsin governor
Scott Walker is up right now I am headed
to the fox Patriot awards at the Hard
Rock Hotel in Hollywood Florida I will
be on Greg gutfeld's show on Friday
we're Taping that from Florida and then
I'm going to do a bunch of other stuff
there I think Tucker is there and a
bunch of other guys I'm going to see if
I can get in the mix on a few other
things we leave you with a cold close
and I sign up oh no I was about to say I
sign out from DC I signed out from DC
but we are live at about 15 minutes with
Senator Ted Cruz another live stream
will be going up we'll recap as much of
this stuff as we can so hang tight for
that and I'll see you soon by its very
existence and character Berlin Remains
the most compelling argument for an open
world
we're reminded of the many traditions of
openness and democracy that have marked
the history of this city
America missed me
[Applause]